bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france donc la campagne
de vaccination elle va débuter demain
puisque les premiers vaccins files
heures biotech sont arrivés sur le
territoire est ce qu'on est prêt écoutez
vous avez vu dans votre reportage
montrait que le dispositif est quand
même très complexe on pourra pas
vacciner la population avec un
dispositif auxi complexe que celui là
j'espère que d'autres vaccins plus
facile à transporter pourront être
rapidement disponible autrement je pense
que l'on va vite être en difficulté au
niveau personnel et mobilisations
nécessaires
nous avons d'autres choses à faire il
faut qu'on s'occupe des autres patients
et vous savez le problème sur ce vaccin
c'est la confiance et la confiance et
bien c'est avec le médecin traitant la
firme hier le personnel qu'on connaît
pas ce gros dispositif très compliqué
qui n'est pas très rassurant quand même
pour la population or il faut rassurer
la population sur le fait que nous avons
besoin de nous faire vacciner
et si possible effectivement qu'on soit
rexie n'est le plus rapidement possible
et pas uniquement les personnes en ehpad
vous savez les personnes à risque sont
toutes les personnes de plus de 65 ans
est pas unique en cédant népal
or là le dispositif en plusieurs étapes
interroge une partie des personnes âgées
en particulier celles qui ne sont pas en
ehpad qu'ils sont à domicile et qui
aimerait bien pouvoir se faire vacciner
assez rapidement partie du dispositif
qui interroge tout le monde finalement
parce que justement le fait que cette
campagne de vaccination est elle débute
dans deux ehpad bien distincts est-ce
que ça c'est réellement de nature à
rassurer l'opinion publique et non parce
que voyez pourquoi choisir ce n est pas
d y en a une dans mon département dans
un établissement l'assistance publique
pourquoi ce cet établissement est pas un
autre enfin on voit que il ya beaucoup
de communication on voit le ministre
bon qui se promènent passe dans les
médias
vous savez j'ai assisté il est très
important de rétablir la confiance de la
population et rétablir la confiance de
la population
c'est que la vaccination sur la plus
simple possible
et les professionnels de santé ans qui
chaque patient a le plus confiance c'est
son médecin traitant
donc il va falloir on sait que de toute
façon ces vaccins sont en nombre limité
pour l'instant c'est pour ça que ça
démarre très lentement
je pense que tant qu'on n'aura pas un
vaccin qui comme les autres vaccins dont
on a l'habitude eh bien vous savez
peut-être disponible beaucoup plus
facilement qu'avec tout ce dispositif
des congélateurs à -80 degré etc pour un
système de santé qui les a on surcharge
aujourd'hui si joli ça va être compliqué
si on peut s'appuyer que sur ce vaccin
va falloir que rapidement on puisse
avoir d'autres vaccins disponibles et
les vaccins qu'ils puissent être
transportés beaucoup plus facilement
qu'ils puissent être disponibles auprès
des médecins traitants dans les
quartiers plutôt que ce dispositif très
très lourd que vous avez montré dans
votre reportage et vous pensez à un
accent particulier il y en a d'autres en
cours de commercialisation énormément de
vaccins qui sont à l'heure actuelle à
l'étude
ce qui est dommage c'est que le champion
français de la pharmacie sanofi qui est
a priori des laboratoires qui était
spécialisée dans les vaccins n'ai pas
été capable de mettre au point un vaccin
c'est peut-être dû au fait que il a
supprimé des milliers d'emplois en
particulier en france et que son pdg
lui-même il ya quelques mois
ne croyez pas aux vaccins en particulier
la technique de la rn messager et il n'a
pas fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
développer avec ça sur les bases
classiques et ce vaccin de sanofi nous
est à noter que au mieux à l'automne
c'est dommage il faut que l'ensemble des
laboratoires fassent les efforts
nécessaires sur le temps qu'ils sont
largement financés par des fonds publics
avec ces pré commandes de vaccin fasse
l'effort de mettre à disposition une
diversité de vaccins qui nous permette
effectivement de pouvoir avoir le nom de
max à disposition des vaccins différents
parce qu'on a vu que les effets
secondaires n'étaient pas forcément les
mêmes parce que si on n'a que un ou deux
vaccins et qui s'avère qu'il ya des
effets secondaires avec certains et pas
avec d'autres bienfaits pour l'adapter
la stratégie au fil de l'an
justement parlez des effets secondaires
il ya la défiance des français elles
sont vos progressé puisque seuls 40% des
personnes interrogées par santé publique
france disent vouloir être vaccinés
contre 53% à 1 mois et demi plus tôt
vous qu'on vous recevez des patients que
vous distille de quoi ont-ils peur ils
entendent surtout ça utilisons il ya une
méfiance vis-à-vis du gouvernement
l'attitude de la population est très
variable d'un pays à l'autre à vous
savez que par exemple en grande-bretagne
j'avais 85% de la population qui a
confiance dans le vaccin
pourquoi 40% en france parce qu'il ya
une défiance vis-à-vis du gouvernement
et quand il ya cette défiance vis à vis
gouvernement je pense que c'est
contreproductif que ça soit le ministre
de la santé oms qui la population n'a
pas confiance qu'ils fassent la
promotion du vaccin la promotion du
vaccin elle doit elle fait par les
professionnels de santé en qui la
population a confiance
toute cette médiatisation autour des
politiques et contre-productive et c'est
un professionnel de santé qui vous le
dit voilà donc les gens ont un problème
de communication peut-être christophe
prudhomme vous allez vous en dire un peu
plus sur les effets secondaires de ce
vaccin c'est probablement ce qui
inquiète aussi énormément
1 les français écoutent et les effets
secondaires c'est comme pour tout
médicament il peut y avoir des effets
secondaires pour les effets secondaires
principaux avec bon les quelques
dizaines de milliers de patients qui ont
déjà été vaccinées sonder les réactions
allergiques ça on sait avec tout vaccin
il payant ses réactions allergiques donc
les professionnels de santé ont été
informés qu'il fallait partir en
vigilant a priori ces réactions
allergiques sont très peu fréquents pas
vous savez bon on a eu quelques
accidents avec des bac 5 avait été mis
sur le marché à ses 60 70 dernières
années mais ils qui voit quand même s'il
faut insister auprès de la population
c'est que globalement normalement les
vaccins c'est un des principaux progrès
de la médecine
au cours de ces 150 dernières années
donc il faut quand même avoir confiance
dans les vaccins
mais après il faut effectivement que il
y ait plus de transparence savait que
les laboratoires nez
oubliez les études qu après qu une
pression très forte était fait sur eux
et après qu'ils aient eu l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché
écoutez c'est contre-productif vis-à-vis
de la population on aimerait bien qu'ils
aient plus de transparence des vaccins
des de la part des fabricants de vaccins
et qui ne votent pas pour ne pas mettre
à disposition de l'ensemble des
professionnels et de la population leurs
études sous couvert sous couvert du
secret commercial
j'arrive à un moment donné c'est pas du
commerce le vaccin c'est un bien
nécessaire pour l'ensemble de la
population
donc il faut que un certain nombre de
barrières comme celle du secret
commercial saute on est dans l'urgence
aujourd'hui est que vous ayez des
laboratoires qui invoque le secret
commercial le risque de concurrence etc
écoutez ce vaccin c'est pas pour se
faire du pognon c'est pas pour que les
laboratoires engrangent des bénéfices
c'est pour qu'on puisse sortir
c'est une des armes c'est pas la seule
c'est une des armes contre l'épidémie
alors l'autre élément important
vis-à-vis de la population il osa christ
africains gratuitement
oui le vaccin n'est pas la seule arme à
notre disposition c'est une arme parmi
d'autres et c'est pas l'armé absolue
d'une efficacité à 100% il faudra
continuer à respecter les gestes
barrière il faudra continuer à ce que
les hôpitaux puissent avoir les moyens
l'hospitalité les patients qui en ont
besoin donc ne surent valorisons pas non
plus le vaccin l'épidémie risque de
durer encore plusieurs mois ou plusieurs
années vac sent pas merci beaucoup avant
christophe prudhomme d'avoir répondu à
nos questions des reds rappelle que vous
êtes médecin urgentiste délégué cgt
santé et porte parole de l'association
médecins urgentistes de france